Anyways,
so you're always in a situation,
and this is occurs across multiple
levels of analysis because I could say,
well,
when are you in the garden?
And one answer could be,
well,
when you're in a beautiful house or in a
beautiful hotel or in a well functioning
institution or in a city that's working,
but I can also say you're in a garden
when your conception of the world is
sufficient that when you enacted it
allows the world to be fruitful.
That's a garden too,
right?
Because so your internal psychological
structure,
the conceptions that you use first of
all,
there obviously analogous to culture,
but they're also analogous to a garden
in that way and light culture,
they can be disrupted.
So you know what it's like people,
they say this all the time.
I wish that hadn't happened and what
they mean by that is Jesus.
I was in a pretty good place before that
event occurred.
You know,
on a big moral eric and really do that
to you.
You know,
you do something that you really think
is stupid and you know you.
You're just shattered.
Really sometimes sheltered enough to
develop post traumatic stress disorder
so you can't get rid of the snakes.
That's the first idea in the story.
Well then the issue is,
well,
what do you do with the stakes?
What God basically told even Adam not
well,
he didn't really tell them not to
interact with the snakes and he put a
snake in there.
I think it's partly because in a sense
it's not possible to create a garden
without having a snake in it because you
can't keep everything out.
It's not possible.
Okay,
so the snake comes along and it says,
well,
if you do this thing that God
for bade a lot of wonderful things will
happen.
Well,
this is where it gets.
It gets extraordinarily complicated.
You know,
let me finish this part of the story and
then we'll go back.
The serpent said unto the woman,
you shall not surely die for God knows
that in the day you eat thereof,
then your eyes will be opened and you
will be as gods knowing good and evil.
Okay,
so what can we conclude from that?
Well,
first thing is,
is that their eyes were closed because
if they weren't closed and how could
they be opened and the second thing is
they didn't know the difference between
good and evil.
Okay?
So that explains the whole shame naked
and not ashamed issue because if your
eyes are closed,
while that's irrelevant and if,
you know,
if,
if there's no moral knowledge,
there's obviously no shame.
So what's happening here is that there's
a very,
um,
profound distinction being made between
the before fruit eating state of being
in the after fruit eating state of being
or the before fruit eating and snake
interacting mode of being and the after
fruit eating and snake interacting mode
of being.
And I think it's reasonable to think of
that on a historical timeline.
You know,
that that is one of the major.
Those are two of the major forces that
shaped our evolutionary history and the
idea that things were different before
that and after that is a perfectly
reasonable presupposition.
Something put us on the path to very,
very rapid cortical development.
Vision is certainly one of those
factors.
So,
and the fruit eating element,
well that's where we have color vision,
so when it isn't obvious exactly what
that did,
but it did a lot and things so.
And then the next thing is,
well there's no moral knowledge now
that's interesting because it implies
that there's some tight link between
having your eyes closed and not having
moral knowledge.
So to have your eyes closed just to not
to be able to see.
So there's a kind of unconsciousness
about it.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her.
And he did eat
and the eyes of both of them were opened
and they knew they were naked and they
sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons.
Okay.
So that's quite an interesting sequence
of events.
So they're tempted by this thing that's
subtle and dangerous and the consequence
of the temptation is the ingestion of
something.
The incorporation of something with
transformative properties.
And the transformation is profound.
What happens is they open their eyes.
Well,
that's coming to consciousness.
That's exactly what that is.
You know,
when a kitten opens its eyes,
it finally enters the world.
You know,
so people had their eyes closed before
this event.
Well,
so they weren't.
They weren't conscious in the same way.
And that would account for the unity of
experience.
They're not separated from.
They're not separate beings on the
ground of existence.
That's one way of thinking.
But they have the same kind of life as
animals too.
You know,
they're,
they're just unconscious or at least non
self conscious entities of nature.
There's no nakedness,
there's no knowledge of good and evil.
I mean,
do you,
you don't blame a lion for eating it,
for eating a sheep.
Yeah.
They used to eat sheep in the Middle
East,
right?
You don't think that's an evil.
They don't think of the lion is evil.
You just think that that's what lions
do.
Now someone comes along and steals your
sheep.
Well that's a whole different issue.
All of a sudden there's a moral issue
that's overlaid upon that and you say,
well,
you might say,
why is all of a sudden there were moral
issue and then the answer to that would
be,
well,
the person either does know the
difference between good and bad or
should know it,
you know,
and if he says,
well,
I'm just acting like a lion,
that's just,
there's just not gonna.
No one's gonna accept that as an excuse.
And the reason for that is there's a
basic assumption that there's something
that you know that lions don't and why?
Well,
it's because your eyes are open in a
different way.
Okay,
well that seems to be reasonable.
So they opened their eyes and bang,
they know they're naked.
Now.
That's an interesting juxtaposition.
Okay,
so let's say you develop a higher form
of consciousness and that makes you self
conscious.
So there's two things happening here.
There's an elevation of consciousness,
but out of that spring,
self consciousness,
and then you've got to think,
well,
what does selfconsciousness mean
exactly?
Well,
because you're not fully self conscious
and the reason you're not fully self
consciousness because you don't know
everything about yourself,
right?
So you're,
you're ignorant of a lot of your own
being,
but there's a lot of your being.
You're not ignorant about.
Well,
hey,
you can identify yourself as an
individual,
so you've got the identify yourself in
the mirror trick down,
which is kind of the standard trick for
animals,
self consciousness,
but that's only the beginning.
It's the bear,
beginnings of self consciousness.
If you're so.
If you're self conscious,
you know where your boundaries are
because what's inside the boundary is
you and what's outside isn't you?
But then there's other boundaries that
you have.
There's a temporal boundary.
There's,
there's the time when you weren't,
and there was the time when you won't
be,
and so there's a boundary of space,
but there's a boundary in time and that
means that as soon as you become self
conscious,
you know that you're going to die.
And so that's the type link between the
fruit of the tree of knowledge of good
and evil and the and death in the Old
Testament or in the genesis story.
So and you might say,
well you were going to die before
and fair enough,
but there's a big difference between a
death,
that death of a self conscious entity
and death in the one case.
It's a natural process that you know
that that's natural death,
let's say.
And the other one,
it's a,
it's a catastrophe of being for the self
conscious individual.
You know.
And so the other thing that happens is
in the genesis story that that discovery
is portrayed as a permanent rift in the
structure of Ba.
That's why it's such a deep sin.
It's like all of a sudden everything is
different and it will never be the same
again.
No matter what happens,
you know when you might say,
well obviously God was an enemy of
higher consciousness.
It's like,
well,
there's lots of interpretations of
generous.
That took exactly that.
Stats said,
well God was an enemy of higher
consciousness.
You wanted things to remain in an,
in an unconscious paradise and that it
was human,
um,
unwillingness to behave and curiosity
that God has sent to the problem that
we're in and it's actually actually a
catastrophe,
you know?
And then other people who were sort of
high that had more say,
admiration for the illumination and self
consciousness elements said that the
thing that tempted human beings was a
greater God than the God that originally
did the creation.
That was a gnostic idea.
You know.
So the serpent therapy becomes an agent
of revelation in a sense,
you know,
but anyways,
this,
they've laid out the problem,
this is the problems.
All of a sudden people woke up and when
they woke up,
they noticed who they were and they
weren't happy about it.
So what do they notice?
They're naked.
Okay,
well,
so what?
Well,
you know,
you see,
so what?
Instantly,
because the first thing they do is make
fig leaves.
They make
clothing out of fiddly and cover
themselves up.
While you know,
that's,
that's culture and you think,
well what's good?
What is the utility of culture?
But that's easy.
Culture is the barrier between us and
our own nakedness.
It's the barrier between our nakedness
and the natural world.
It's like,
why do you put on clothes so you don't
freeze to death,
you know,
so you're not as easily attacked.
It's like as soon as you know you're
naked and vulnerable and you're self
conscious,
you extend yourself across time,
you discovered time,
you know that not only are you
vulnerable now,
but you're going to be vulnerable in the
future.
So are your children and their children.
It's like the whole nature of being.
It's like you've added a dimension to
the nature of being.
You've added time to it and it's a
radical transformation.
You might say,
well that's good because lions don't eat
you as often.
It's like,
yeah,
the zebras don't seem that upset on the
plains of the Serengeti when the lions
are around.
One's going to pick one off now and
then,
but the lion,
the zebras aren't running around,
you know,
with anxiety disorders,
popping value them all the time because
the lions are there,
but that's not the case with human
beings.
We see a line and we think,
oh yeah,
some at some point that line's going to
want to eat one of us and so,
and lions in general will do that.
So not only do we have to solve the
problem of that line right now,
we have to solve the problem of all
lions for all time,
which we actually seem to be doing a
very good job of now because soon there
won't be any of them,
but you know,
so that sort of thing can get out of
hand.
But,
but you get the point.
So okay.
So they sewed fig leaves together and
they made themselves aprons.
So
you know,
the sexual element of it too is I think
also that the reason sexuality is tied
in there so tightly is because the most
sexual parts of a human being are also
the parts that are the most vulnerable.
So.
So it's not only,
you know,
vulnerability to judgment
and vulnerability to exploitation,
which is a huge deal,
especially in the case of women.
But it's also the fact that just from a
purely physical perspective,
those are the most delicate tissues.
And so the fact that they are fully
exposed is really a big problem.
So okay,
so now they're naked.
They got aprons on.
It's like,
no,
they're not in unconscious paradise
anymore.
So then what happens?
And they heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day,
and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God
amongst the trees of the garden.
I can't imagine how you could possibly
pack more meaning into two sentences.
You know,
it's,
you can tell people have been at this
for like 25,000 years because see what
happens here is that there's an idea to
begin with,
that there's a complete unity between
God and his creation,
let's say,
so that there's the natural order is
undisturbed and all of a sudden that's
fractured.
And so what happens is that human beings
are divorced from the divinity.
It's.
And not only are they divorced from it,
they're unwilling to expose themselves
to it.
So,
so think about.
Think about this.
I will take a take a side step for a
minute.
You might say,
well,
imagine that you could exist in a manner
that was on perfect.
The question might be,
well,
what would stop you from doing it?
Well,
one thing might be that you couldn't
envision something as useless as you are
actually managing that you know,
so you,
you know.
If you think about what stands in the
road of people as obstacles to their
full self realization,
the easiest way to encapsulate that is
that they view themselves as inadequate.
Now there's other things as well.
They don't want to take the
responsibility and so forth,
but you know it's very difficult to heat
a divine call.
Let's say when you're stuck in this
little ratty contraption that is prone
to disease and I'm prone to shame and
prone to age and prone to death,
and it's like how can you continue in
some divine manner when you've come to
the realization that there are,
you are,
you know,
and people,
certainly people derive the conclusion
fairly frequently that there are so
appalling,
but it would be better if they were
obliterated along with everyone else.
It's not as if the realization of the
nature of our own physical being was
something that freed people up to be
courageous.
You know,
it was quite the reverse.
Although I think people can still be
courageous in front of it and in spite
of it,
but it's definitely in spite of it.
You know,
all the classic definitions of true
courage aren't that you're not afraid.
It's that you're afraid,
but you do it anyways.
It's like,
well,
you that fear is,
and shame is an integral part of you.
As soon as you realize that you're
vulnerable to social evaluation and
natural degeneration,
you're stuck with it,
and so then bang,
you're divorced from your divine mode of
being,
we'll say partly at least because you're
just afraid to manifest it.
So anyways,
that's what happened.
So Adam and Eve hide from God.
Now it seems to be really
counterproductive because you might
think that if they didn't hide from God,
then there wouldn't be a problem.
They can be naked and no problem,
but that isn't what happened and the
Lord God calls onto Adam.
It says unto him,
where are,
where are you?
And Adam says,
I heard your voice in the garden,
so there's a call there,
and I was afraid because I was naked.
Well,
that pretty much explains it and I hit
myself.
Okay?
And God said,
who told you that you were naked?
Have you eaten of the tree whereof I
commanded thee that thou shouldn't show
this naughty?
Who told me that that was naked?
I believe women told men that.
I think that's a very accurate summation
of the relationship between men and
women.
What all we develop consciousness across
the span of evolutionary history.
And I believe it for a couple of
reasons.
Number one,
sexual selection is a huge factor in,
in what created human beings.
And women primarily do the selection.
They're the bottleneck and they're the
bottleneck.
Because women can't have that many
offspring,
they can only have a few.
So that makes them the bottleneck by
definition.
And women are so choosy about men that
twice as many women have children as
men.
Okay?
So what that means is on average means
that I know it's kind of hard to
understand,
but imagine every single woman has one
child.
And then imagine half the men have zero
and half of them have to.
Okay,
that's the case.
So statistically speaking,
half man,
half of all men were write offs.
Now it's actually worse than that
because some men have so many offspring
that is not even funny,
you know.
So that Kinda cuts,
it cuts the number of successful men
down by many.
So women are a bottleneck and they do
judgment and and rightly so and they
judged them according to their
insufficiency.
And that is what makes men
unselfconscious obviously.
And it's the thing that makes them more
self conscious than anything else.
Now to men's credit,
let me tell you about the bower birds.
Okay.
So bowerbirds,
they're very cool.
They live on the ground and the males
make these incredibly.
First of all,
we've a nest.
It's sort of like a hammock.
It's real soft.
And then they hang that into tree and
then they sweep out their front yard and
then they decorate it with bits of like
the blue leaves are over here.
And then there's some red leaves here
and there's a nice display of green
here.
And maybe there's some glass there and
it's like this little art work,
you know,
and the bower birds have these more or
less enroll say in the same territory.
And then the females come hopping along
and they take a look at this thing and
if they like it,
well then they're willing to become a
little more friendly with that
particular bowerbird.
And if they don't,
they fly away.
Well.
So if the male bowerbird has three
female visitors and nothing pans out,
then he,
you know,
he has a little fit and erases all
creation that he asked to do another
one.
And so like you just have to think about
that for 15 minutes and it pretty much
explains human beings just like men.
One response that man could have had was
just to go hide in a shell.
And some of them do that.
That is absolutely a common response.
And to never come out and spend the rest
of his life playing video games in the
basement and eating Cheetos,
you know?
But then you know,
the other responses,
well,
all better transform myself into
something that isn't going to produce
that response.
And that's a central part of,
that's a central part of male
motivation.
It's a central element of male
So if you're ever wondering why men are
the way they are,
that real answer to that is because
that's how they evolve to oppress women.
So because obviously if that wouldn't
have happened,
given that sexual selection is such a
powerful selecting force among human
beings,
well it wouldn't have worked out.
So men,
women don't make men self conscious,
you know,
when it's more than that too,
because you could see a positive
feedback loop emerging as we got more
cognitively sophisticated.
You know,
when you can think of that.
Maybe that was an arms race between men,
women and snakes,
something like that.
You know,
as we got more cognitively
sophisticated,
one of the prices we paid for that was
that our hand expanded and one of the
prices women paid for that was that
childbirth became increasingly difficult
and the babies kept getting born
younger.
And so that meant that women became
more.
As we became more cognitively able,
paradoxically,
women became more vulnerable at certain
key points of their lives because they
had increasingly fragile babies.
Now,
how did women deal with that?
Well,
I think they shamed men into becoming
caregivers of children because how else
would it have happened?
Like the typical mit mammo mail doesn't
hang around provisioning the litter,
you know,
in fact,
some of the males will eat the comms.
You don't want a black male.
Black bear around wolves are an
exception to this and you know there are
animals that are an exception.
It happens in other species other than
human beings,
but human beings have this incredibly
long period of dependence that also
requires a relationship for that
relationship to the remain in tact.
There has to be a fair bit of integrity
in the communication between the
partners.
So there's a real moral demand there as
well.
So anyways,
Adam doesn't show himself here as a
particularly courageous individual
because,
which I think is quite comical when God
says,
hold,
who told you that you were naked?
Have you eaten of that tree?
Which I told you not to.
The man says,
the woman who you gave to me,
she gave me the tree,
the tree,
and I did eat,
which is it doesn't say much for his
moral character because he rats out the
first chance he gets so,
which I also think isn't like the comedy
of that is underrated in this story.
That's a very funny sequence of events
so
and so the God talks to the woman who
says,
well,
what's this that you did?
And the woman said,
the serpent.
It was the serpent's fault.
The serpent beguiled me and I did eat.
Let me show you out.
I think I've showed you this picture
before,
but it's such a crazy cool picture.
I want to show it to you again.
Okay,
well,
for whatever reason this just doesn't
seem to be working.
So I'll tell you about the picture and
still it's a very car with
representation and Christian iconography
and what it basically shows us that Mary
is holding up this incident.
You know,
up off the ground.
She's got her foot on a snake or a
lizard.
It's like,
well,
it doesn't take a biological genius to
figure out what that means.
It means like the good mother keeps the
baby away from predatory reptiles,
you know,
and so you can see that as part of this
feedback loop that developed,
so there's predation,
it's particularly focused on women and
children,
which is exactly what it would be
focused on.
So and then in order for that to not be
to not the catastrophic,
then the women are appealing to the men
for protection and that starts to
increase because the women gets more
vulnerable as we get smarter and the
babies get smaller.
And so there's this triadic,
positive feedback loop that occurs that
wraps up brain development and we need
it.
There has to be a reason for the brain
development.
This is called a baldwin effect by the
way,
in biology,
the Baldwin effect is where something
happens to produce an outcome,
something biological happens that
produces a cultural outcome that
increases the probability that that
biological adaptations will serve
fitness.
So for example,
beavers cut down trees.
So,
and what that means is that the beavers
that are more adapted to aquatic
environments do better.
So as the beavers get more adapted to
aquatic environments and cutting down
trees,
they cut down more trees and make more
aquatic environments,
and so the thing spins until you get an
animal that's really,
really well adapted to doing precisely
that.
Well,
something happened to our cortex up and
very,
very short order and it was shorter or
you know,
it was so short that the human female
pelvic structure could barely keep up,
which is why birth is so rough.
And why so many children die in
childbirth.
I mean,
it doesn't happen much anymore,
but it used to happen a lot.
But before that,
middle of the 20th century,
women were dying in childbirth all the
time.
Plus it's extraordinarily difficult.
So even though the baby is born
premature,
for all intents and purposes,
it's still hell.
And the reason for that is the hand is
so big and it's even compressible
because the baby's head isn't fully
formed when it's born.
Bones have gaps in them.
So the baby's head compresses and like,
like mad visibly.
So,
so the woman says,
well,
it was the serpent's fault,
so you know,
when you could almost,
you could also say this ties into the
issue of women induced selfconsciousness
among men.
So like if the woman's primary primary
problem is predation,
you know,
for her and the infant because of her
being burdened with the infants and the
infant's complete and absolute inability
to defend itself,
then it's going to drive the probability
that she's going to select someone for a
partner who can get rid of the damn
snakes.
And then you know,
when you see that echoed over and over
and human iconography,
it's like the hero is the person who
confronts the Dragon.
Okay,
well what do you do when you confront?
Drag it?
You get the girl.
That's the first thing.
But more importantly,
you get something of value.
And that's a real transmutation.
It's so interesting because what
happened was not only we figure out how
to defend ourselves against predators,
we figured out that going after them
voluntarily was unbelievably useful
because you might ask,
well,
what the hell transformed,
you know,
frugivores into carnivores.
It's,
you know,
chimps will eat and they do hunt,
they will eat monkeys,
but they primarily live on leaves,
which is pointless,
you know,
because the leaves have no calories
whatsoever.
Well,
human beings like we got transformed.
We are primarily fruit eaters and we
turned into hunters and we're thin and
fast,
which is very unlike a chimpanzee.
So not only were women selecting men who
were able and willing to protect
themselves against predators,
but that got translated even farther
into selection for,
for partners who would go out partly to
protect and partly also didn't want to
bring something back.
So I know it's pretty,
it's a pretty smart arrangement.
All things considered.
But the problem is,
you know,
one of the prices that women pay for
that is that they're partly selecting
for male aggression.
You know,
because the males aren't going to go,
they're not going to be able to do that
sort of thing unless they're tough and
they're not going to go out and do it
unless they're relatively fearless.
So you know,
and then you end up with a,
you got this weird balance between
needing a semi Predator and needing
someone who's going to be able to
integrate themselves into the household.
So that's the beauty and the beast thing
as far as I can tell.
So.
Okay.
So the law God says to the serpent,
because you've done this,
you're cursed above all cattle.
Cattle were generally animals and above
every beast of the field,
upon thy belly you will go and dust you
will eat all the days of your life.
Okay?
So the serpent scoped a problem there.
And uh,
be interesting to find out exactly why
those damn things lost their legs
because you know that snakes,
snakes,
lizards aren't snakes that grew legs.
Snakes are lizards that lost their legs.
The question is,
why did the hell did they lose their
legs?
Like what was it about the specifics of
their environment and their diet and
their locale that meant that legless
movement was better?
Well,
they're sneakier,
you know,
they can slither through the grass,
they can climb trees to.
Although he does do that,
but I don't know enough about snakes to
know exactly why it was that they lost
their legs,
but be interesting to find out and unto
the woman,
and I will put enmity between Dow and
the woman and between seed and her seed,
it shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel.
Okay,
so it's just another representation of
the fact that there's going to be enmity
between human beings and predatory will
say predatory reptiles under the woman.
He said,
oh,
greatly multiply that I sorrow and thy
conception.
That's not hard to figure out in sorrow
shalt thou bring forth children and thy
desire shall be to thy husband and he
shall rule over thee.
Notice that doesn't say should it just
says Shell,
and that's not the same thing at all.
Remember,
this is a curse.
It's not a.
it's not a proposition about how the
world should be optimally structured.
It's far different than not.
It says,
look,
there's been a sequence of events and
this is going to be the outcome.
Childbirth is going to be hell.
It's going to be really difficult to
raise children and you're going to be
subject to the oppression of men.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's definitely what happened.
And then to Adam,
he says,
because you listened to your wife and
ate of the tree,
which I told you not to,
the ground is cursed for your sake.
You'll eat it in sorrow all the days of
your life.
It'll bring up thorns and thistles and
you'll eat the herb of the field.
So that's the introduce deduction of the
necessity of agriculture,
right?
You're no longer living in a garden
where things are just growing for free.
You're out there like dig in with a
stick and planting things,
which is work.
You know when you think,
well,
do animals work and the answer that is
no human beings work.
The answer to that is yes.
Why do human beings work?
How about because we discovered time,
right?
Because work means why do you work while
you worked for the future?
Obviously,
and you don't have the future unless
you've discovered time and you don't
care about the future unless you know
you're vulnerable.
So these things are tangled together and
so the cost of self consciousness is
that we're life becomes work,
life becomes suffering and work.
So it doesn't necessarily seem like a
particularly good deal in the sweat of
value face you shall eat bread until you
return to the ground for out of it.
You were taken for your dust and unto
dust you will return.
And Adam called his wasting eve because
she was the mother of all living and add
unto Adam also and to his wife did the
Lord God make coats of skins and clothed
them.
So okay,
well,
you know,
that's certainly part of the origin of
clothing,
especially in the colder climates,
right?
It's like you get the animal,
maybe it's a Predator and you wear it
to.
And to begin with,
we lived inside of them,
you know.
So I suspect,
although I don't know this for sure,
although I know it fairly well,
the earliest dwellings were mammoth
skins with mammoth bone poles.
And you can see,
see how that might've come about,
right?
Because you're out there hunting a
mammoth.
Maybe you're living in a cave or
wherever the hell people live,
or maybe you made something out of,
you know,
grasp Heidi and I don't know what the
Paleolithic people were living in,
but it starts to get cold.
Maybe the ice age starts creeping up,
right?
And so you stab yourself a nice mammoth
and a storm comes up.
What are you going to do?
What you've skinned it out,
at least in principle.
So you carry the meat home.
The logical thing to do is to get the
hell underneath the skin and after a day
or two in his throw them underneath
erotic mammas skin,
you might think,
well,
it wouldn't be a bad idea to like do
something to the skin so that it's not
quite as intolerable to live under as it
might be if that's a tent,
like a tent.
His skin with bones,
you know?
And then the movement from that to this
is,
well,
it's a matter of degree rather than
kind.
So
and then the Lord God sent the man and
woman or the Lord God says,
behold the man is become one of us to
know good and evil.
So that's the sign of divinity,
to know good and evil,
to have a moral sense,
and now lest he put forth his hand and
take also of the tree of life and eat
and live forever.
Therefore the Lord God sent him forth
from the garden of Eden to till the
ground from whence he was taken.
So we drove out the man and he placed at
the east of the garden of Eden Cherubims
and a flaming sword which turned every
way to keep the way of the tree of life.
Well,
the last part of that,
it's very difficult to understand,
you know,
the tree of life issue.
So the idea there is that there's,
there's at least in principle,
a substance capable of,
of what,
of conferring and mortality,
but we don't have access to that.
And so,
and you know,
part of the return to Eden,
which is also the movement towards
heaven,
which is also the perfection of life,
is to defeat death.
Obviously into find the elixir of
immortality,
which by the way was the goal of the
entire l chemical pursuit and that's
what turned into science and well,
what's the goal of science?
Well,
it's to make us healthy,
wealthy and live,
you know,
conceivably forever.
So you know,
it's not like people aren't continually
trying to get the fruit of the tree of
life.
Now there's a lot more to it than that,
the,
the ending of that,
but,
but what you have there is the expulsion
of human beings from an unconscious
paradise into history.
And that's exactly how the Bible is
structured.
Like what happens is there's these
stories in genesis that are very,
very old.
There's the these stories.
There's the story of Cain and Abel.
There's the story of,
of a Babel,
the tower of Babel.
There's the story of Noah.
Then roughly speaking,
although it happens a bit with no
history starts because then when you get
past that you get to the post flood
period,
select the pre flood period is so back
in prehistory that it's all archaic
mythology and the post flood period,
which basically starts with Abraham,
starts to become a history of the
culture of Israel.
So it's actually,
it's actually literally
it's the history of a culture instead of
the mythologizing nation of radical
prehistory of the past.
So
no,
I think I'll,
I'll also just tell you briefly the Cain
and Abel story because we're there and
we might as well do it.
And this is,
this story is
roughly speaking 12 sentences long.
So,
okay.
So adamant.
Any habit child came and add and eve
says,
I have gotten a man from the Lord.
And again,
she bore his brother Abel and Abel was a
keeper of sheep,
but Cain was a tiller of the ground.
So there's some antagonism between the,
um,
the shepherds and the farmers.
And that's like there's always an
between shepherds and farmers because of
the shepherds,
the sheep to graze all over the place.
And that farmers want the shape to stay
the hell out of the,
out of the fields,
you know,
and that was all played out again in the
American west.
There was huge,
you know,
conflict between the farmers and the
ranchers for exactly the same reason.
So,
and it came in process of time.
It came to pass that cain brought of the
fruit of the ground,
an offering unto the Lord.
All right,
so this is a strange thing.
So we've already talked about the
discovery of time and the necessity for
work.
Okay?
So,
you know,
we don't exactly know how people
conceptualize if those ideas.
It wasn't like they were cave men are
all sitting around the fire one day and
they said,
hey,
you know what?
I just discovered tomorrow we should do
something about that.
We should get to work.
It was God only knows how that happened.
It came out of the inarticulate,
biological substructure that is our past
and started to manifest itself.
God only knows and imaginative ideas,
but one of those,
imagine that the ideas is the idea of
the sacrifice.
You know,
it's the conceptualization of God.
The father as that,
which extends across time and judges,
then you make sacrificial offerings to
that which could be of your labor.
This is the fruits of your labor,
but the difference is trivial.
It's like,
look what I've done.
Is this good enough for you?
And believe me,
you guys are asking that question all
the time.
It's like it's just nonstop.
Is this good enough?
Is this sacrifice enough,
you know,
and what are you hoping for while you're
hoping for the blessings of.
Well,
I would say for all intents and
purposes,
you're hoping for the blessings of God
the father.
Now you might think about it in pure
cultural terms.
That's fine.
From a psychological perspective,
it hardly makes any difference at all.
The point is is that to conceptualize
culture across time as a judgmental male
is a really smart idea.
It's a really,
really smart idea.
So.
And then it's just judgmental mail that
you have to make offerings to.
It's like,
yeah,
that's,
that's pretty much exactly right.
Okay,
so that's what's happening and so people
are acting this out.
You have to make sacrifices.
Cane brings some vegetables and fruit
and,
uh,
able brings no,
he brings like some lamps and these are
the high quality labs right there,
the choice cuts and uh,
we know that partly because the
firstling of the flock,
so that's the first born,
um,
say lambs,
they're there,
they had a reputation as the most
valuable and partly because of the
firstborn son was the most valuable.
It's the same kind of idea and there's a
reason the first born son was most
valuable and part of the reason is,
is that unless you give all your land to
one of your children by 12 generations,
all of your offspring are living on
something the size of a postage stamp
and they're all starving to death.
So it's unfair in a sense that it only
goes to the firstborn son.
But if it's an agricultural community,
there's no better solution.
And then at least you can tell your
second born son like,
well,
yeah,
you're a fine guy.
And you know,
it would be wonderful if you could get
something but you don't get it.
And it's not your fault.
It's not a mindful leader.
It's just that's just the rule and so
that's a good deal for everybody.
You know,
you don't get the farm,
you have to go make your own way,
but at least there's no enmity
associated with it necessarily.
So anyways,
cane makes this offering that looks like
it's about equality and God is happy
about that
and the Lord had respect unto Abel and
to his offering.
Now the book,
the story that makes this ambiguous say
you can kind of guess that the reason
that Abel gets away with it is because
while a,
he's bringing neat rather than
vegetables.
Okay,
so that's higher quality,
much more,
much more nutrient dense.
It's much higher quality offering a food
and then it's also the of the meat.
It's the highest quality and so,
and then the next thing that happens is
it's acceptable to God.
So you know,
it might be the enabled just got it
right and God was happy or maybe God's
happy about able for some completely
arbitrary reason it out it and it
actually doesn't matter at all.
You get value out of both
interpretations.
I mean,
I would say to err on the safe side that
offered the most valuable things is
probably your best bet,
but there is an art.
There's some respect for the arbitrary
nature of God to hear too.
You can't exactly be sure why he's not
happy with Kane.
So anyways,
it doesn't matter until Cain and his
offering,
he had not respect and Cain was very
wroth angry that his and his countenance
fall.
So like this is a permanent
disappointment for him.
He's angry,
resentful,
unhappy,
miserable.
All of those things he's failing.
That's what it says.
Fundamentally,
like if God isn't pleased by his
offerings,
what happens is he's failing and this
makes him very angry.
And then the Lord says,
what?
What's up with you?
Why are you angry and why has your face
fallen the way it has?
And uh,
he says more,
and this is where it gets.
It seems.
The story seems to reveal that this
actually has something to do with Kane
rather than something to do with God.
So God says,
if you do well,
won't you be accepted?
Well,
that implies he wasn't doing well.
And if you don't do well,
then it's your fault.
And so God is saying,
don't,
don't bring your damn problems to me,
buck.
Oh,
it's like,
if this isn't working out for you,
it's because you're just not doing it
right.
You know you're,
you're not into this properly,
you're not doing well.
And also you're blending things that
shouldn't be blamed.
Now there's an interesting part of this.
So
the way that the story is sin lies at
your door was told,
it was told in a metaphorical structure
and sin was something that was
conceptualized as I lustful predatory
animal like a cat.
And so it was probably at Kane's door.
That's the metaphor.
And the idea is that cane allows this
thing in to have intercourse with him.
So there's this participation in like a
sexualized merger.
And so there's a,
there's an implication there.
And the implication is not only is
there's sin out the door,
but cain invites it in.
And how's it creative relationship,
like an intimately creative relationship
with it.
Now that's ridiculously smart because
that's what happens if people are
resentful because their offerings were
either second rate or got rejected,
you know,
one of the pathways is first they get
very,
very angry and their accountant is false
or they're resentful and hostile and
then the next thing is,
you know,
the little resentful fantasy start to
emerge and instead of thinking,
Huh,
that's not a very productive way to go
because it is like a door.
They think,
oh,
let's just see where we can go with
this.
And like after five or six years of
that,
you're in a prime position to go shoot
up Dawson College.
No,
you can go very far down that rabbit
hole.
And it's,
it's,
it's clearly motivated by the rejection
of the fruits of your being by
existence.
That's how you're going to interpret it
so
well.
And then so,
so kane obviously he's not happy with
that response.
Not In the least because it says exactly
the opposite of what he would like it to
say.
You know,
first of all,
that it's his own fault that he could do
something about it and then he doesn't
get to blame being and God,
so ken goes and has a chat with Abel and
it came to pass when they were in the
field that Cain rose up against Abel,
his brother and killed him.
Well,
the first story about real human beings
in the Bible is a murder.
It's a fratricide and it's.
It's the.
It's the antagonistic brothers,
one who is an archetype of good that's
able,
the others who have an archetype of evil
and those develop across time.
It's an it's an echoing or appreciate
doing.
That's another way of thinking about it.
If the battle between Christ and Satan,
because those are more.
There are more purely archetipal figures
and much more fleshed out,
but it's the earliest manifestation of
that idea.
The hostile brothers and what you get.
It's so sophisticated because basically
what it says is that if you do badly or
you work hard either way and God rejects
your offerings and you become angry and
resentful,
the first thing you're going to do is go
after the best thing you could possibly
imagine and do your best to wipe it out
and you might say,
well,
why would you do that?
Well,
if there's a bunch of reasons,
well first of all,
it would feel good.
Second,
you get revenge against God because of
course this is God's favorite,
so if you can take him out of the
equation,
it's like that's a great deal.
Third,
the ideal against which you're
negatively contrasting yourself is now
gone because that's the problem with
having an ideal.
If you have an ideal,
then you're unworthy and it that's okay.
If you think the ideal is attainable or
even if you can move towards it,
but if all of a sudden the ideal is
unattainable and you're sort of cast
among the damned the probability that
you're going to be able to view that
ideal.
Anything other than your enemy is very
low and so cain kills them,
so that's interesting because that
really means that's the end of it.
For cain,
he's destroyed his own ideal.
Well,
how do you live then?
How do you live?
If you've destroyed your own ideal,
you've got nowhere to go,
and so kane is so angry that he's
willing to destroy his own ideal to
obtain revenge and and,
and,
and that's
12 lines story right at the beginning of
history and that's the layout for the
spirit of humanity.
It says,
we became self conscious,
our eyes open,
we became self conscious.
We recognized our vulnerability and an
attempt to overcome that.
We started to work and sacrifice,
but the problem with that is sometimes
that didn't work.
Maybe because God was feeling
particularly arbitrary that day or
because we're kind of useless either
way.
When it doesn't work,
that's not good because it's our only
remaining defense.
And so then what?
Well then it's a choice.
It's more,
it's more choice right there between
good and evil.
And that's all foreshadowed in the first
story.
So now I'll add one more thing to this.
It took me a long time to figure out,
I thought,
well,
what the hell is the connection between
the knowledge of good and evil and
nakedness and vulnerability and an
awareness,
and I thought,
okay,
there's,
there's production and there's evil,
so the lion kills the foreign and eats
it.
It's rough.
That's a tragedy.
Do you capture an enemy?
And then you keep them alive for three
weeks in pain before you kill them.
There's a lot more there than tragedy
that's malevolence.
And then he might say,
well,
how is it that you can come up with
malevolence?
And I would say as soon as your self
conscious,
you can come up with malevolence because
if I know how I'm vulnerable and I know
that you're like me,
all I have to do is figure out what the
worst possible thing would be for me and
then I can do it to you.
And so you don't get the knowledge of
self conscious vulnerability without
instantly also obtaining the Norwich of
the difference between good and evil.
And that's also another thing that
really distinguishes people because we
can do things that are so terrible that
they make any of the things that animals
do look positively forgivable.
So you know that long without self
consciousness comes this tremendous
widening of the capacity for fracture
from just natural tragedy,
let's say just natural life to this
whole spectrum of the ultimate in good
and the ultimate evil.
And then as soon as that happens,
the first thing we have is a display of
that in in dramatic form.
And that's the Cain and Abel Story.
Now,
interestingly enough,
and this is the last thing that I'll
tell you,
God doesn't kill Cain.
We can talk about why that is later.
But cain has children and s and keynes
descendants,
I think three generations down.
So if you killed one again,
sons,
he killed seven of you.
They kill seven of you.
And if you kill one of keynes
grandchildren,
then they killed 49 of you and then and
so forth until you get to this guy named
Tubal Kane who is either the grandson or
the great grandson.
I don't remember which.
And in tradition,
he's the first person who makes weapons
of war.
So there's this idea that the sacrifice
fails and that produces this descent
into murderous resentment.
And then that can amplify across a
culture and possess more and more people
until what happens is it finally erupts
in full,
full scale war.
And that's more than territoriality,
right?
It's more than a territorial dispute
because you can understand territorial
disputes.
This is territorial dispute with
malevolence.
And you know,
that's something that you,
that doesn't need any explanation.
We,
everyone understands what that is.